welcome to the show everybody what I
what I really like to say at the top
here of the show is just thank you thank
you for your tireless ceaseless support
because the big victory that I achieved
last night
is really your victory this is about
this isn't about me it's about you it's
about us it's about what we've achieved
together and and it's because of you
that I can sit here right now today and
say that despite very minimal
campaigning on my part and despite
spending no money and despite not even
being in the race frankly I managed to
win only eighteen fewer delegates than
Michael Bloomberg that is just
remarkable and and I spent 500 million
fewer dollars to do it so that's what
this campaign is all about it's one of
the great underdog stories in the
history of American politics I think so
again thank you thank you so much we are
really building a movement here now on
the show today Super Tuesday of course
we'll discuss the results and the the
ridiculous wines from the Bernie bro
horde now claiming that the whole thing
was rigged it's rigged it's rigged
against them because because he didn't
do as well as they'd hoped
why is it these days that after every
election the loser always says that the
election was rigged has it always been
this way as if though people have always
done in our the elections actually
rigged is that the case
we'll discuss also we'll go through your
five headlines plus not to add insult to
injury but I do need to cancel Bloomberg
today the primary voters already
cancelled him already took care of that
but I think I need to double down on the
cancellation because of something that
he did yesterday that is just I'll play
the footage for you if you haven't seen
it it is it is really shocking it's in
my opinion I'm not even exaggerating or
joking it's the most shocking footage of
a politician certainly the most
grotesque footage of a politician I've
ever seen in my life
so what we'll get to that as well now
last night I don't think I need to go
into recounting all of the vote totals
and everything because first of all
you've heard it already also who cares
but very quickly Joe Biden won one
big picks up nine states including Texas
Bernie won California and three other
states Bloomberg with the most
significant victory of the night one
American Samoa and still decided to
suspend his campaign even though he won
American Samoa you would think from
there you know you could build a
nationwide campaign wasn't able to do it
unfortunately so that puts the delegate
count right now at 453 to 373 Biden over
Bernie with the rest of the the
candidates what few remain hanging out
with a with a handful here and there
Tulsi has I think one delegate Klobuchar
got more than she did and she's not even
in the race Warren earned barely more
than Budaj edge even though Budaj
also is not in the race and the only
possible reason for that of course for
Warren's poor performance
the only possible reason can be sexism
and racism against Native American women
but here's the point I want to make out
at the outset today as as anyone could
have predicted Bernie's fans are on TV
and they're on social media and saying
that the election was rigged it's all
it's all one big rigged game they rigged
it against Bernie hashtag rigged primary
was trending number one on Twitter this
morning and this is how it always goes
after every election now this is this is
what happens now I I feel like there was
a time maybe I'm wrong I seem to
remember a time many moons ago when you
could have an election and the results
would come in and nobody would scream
that it was rigged people would be mad
or they would be sad or they'd be glad
or they'd be defiant or or they might
even you know they they'll complain
about it in all different various ways
but there wasn't this perfunctory
reaction this automatic reflex of
immediately claiming the whole thing was
rigged in fact it used to be that to
claim that an election is rigged was a
really serious charge that you didn't
take lightly because think about what
you're saying but now it's just it's
automatic besides it's a rigged rig rig
didn't it cuts the left and right we do
this it's on both sides
now like I said think about this for a
minute if you really think our elections
are rigged and that it's all decided in
some dark smoky room and that our votes
don't even matter at all then first of
all you can never celebrate when you're
favored candidate wins so even the
Bernie bros they're they're upset that
he didn't win more states but they're
happy about California he won California
it's the he won the most delegates in a
single state last night they're
celebrating that well if it's rigged
then that was rigged too right
so you're celebrating a rigged election
because it went in your favor does that
make you a hypocrite if you really
believe that our election our rigs our
elections are rigged that we are no
different from a banana republic we're
no different from a dictatorship we're
no different from North Korea if that's
really what you think then what are you
doing sitting around crying about it why
aren't you taken to the streets and
armed revolution that's what our
founding fathers certainly would have
done yeah you're sitting around sending
hashtags hashtag rigged election that's
how you're addressing the problem if you
if you actually believe that then this
is this is we don't have a democratic
system this is not a republic we live in
in absolute tyranny and oppression we
live essentially in a dictatorship we
have we have no freedoms that that's
that's the implication so again I asked
what are you doing sitting around just
whining is it because you don't really
believe what you're saying see this this
is what happens it's very easy and the
Internet has made it even easier to sit
back and make extraordinary charges and
claims about the way things work but you
don't have to back it up but most people
sang it are anonymous anyway so you
don't have to do anything you don't have
to back up what you're saying you don't
have to act on it you just you just say
it and so everyone's just saying things
now I want to get to the real point here
about this election rigging claim
because I
that the what what ends up happening
because of it is that you have the
further infantilize ation of the
American voter and the American people
by extension so I want to talk about
that but first let's check in quickly a
word from our very good friends over at
VIN Charo you know having a great watch
that kind of puts you a step above
everybody else in the in a style
department that it not only makes you
feel great about yourself but it makes
you feel it makes you feel more superior
and more worthy that's how I'm put onto
the chair watch I know that I'm I'm
better than everybody else I'll be
frankly now I already know that about
myself so but the watch confirms how
much better I am than everybody else and
that's that's what I like about if
you're looking to upgrade your look you
don't waste money on a cheap cookie
cutter watch it doesn't get you noticed
no one's gonna pay attention to its it
looks like the same cheap garbage
everybody else is wearing don't do that
VIN charile understands the frustrations
of online shopping so they make it easy
by offering free shipping 30-day returns
guarantees and also guarantees for your
watch for two years so now you're not
gonna want to return the watch I pretty
much guarantee that but you also but you
do have you do have that option so
there's really no risk there's no
there's no reason not to go online go to
Finch arrow watches and and and get a
watch and see how you like it head over
to VIN chera watch's calm slash Walt you
can check out my favorite picks take
advantage of my special discount while
you shop as well but remember to use
code Walsh when you go there you know
I've got several Finch arrow watches
right now and what I like most about
them is that you you know somebody sees
the watch they assume that you spend
probably exorbitant amounts of money on
it because it's a it's it's a very
well-made watch it's also very
comfortable which is which is important
too it's an underrated aspect of watches
that they actually are comfortable if
they sit on your your wrist in a
comfortable way it doesn't feel like
you're lugging around a huge brick or
something attached to your rich your
wrist so it looks like you spent a lot
of my buddy but but you didn't because
you can get great deals on Finch arrow
watches if you go there now Finch arrow
watches com so go there now show the
world what you look like at your best go
to VI ncer o watches calm
forward slash Walsh and use my code
walls for a discount at checkout don't
pay full price on these beautiful
timepieces use my code Walsh at checkout
okay now back to this rigging thing of
course you know we know how it goes the
attitude of most people is that the
election is rigged if it goes against
them if it goes against my guy my guy
loses then it must be that that it's
rigged now if he wins then it was a pure
and unimpeachable process and the wishes
of the American people were accurately
reflected that's how it goes
so this rigged election claim is nothing
more than the blubbering z' of a child
the you know screaming because his
sister has more cereal than he does in
his bowl
it's not fair everyone's against me it's
not fair shut up was the election rigged
against Bernie no it wasn't but what if
what if the establishment that
mysterious establishment that shadowy
force told Warren to stay in the race in
order to siphon votes from Bernie what
if that happened because she certainly
did siphon votes from Bernie Bernie
would have won Massachusetts main I
think Minnesota would have picked up
more delegates in other states if it
wasn't for Warren so Warren staying in
the race so serve no purpose other than
to and I used this term not totally
literally sabotage her supposed
ideological allied what does that mean
well it means first of all that Warren
is a charlatan and a fraud and an
egomaniac and this was always just a
vanity project on her part but does it
mean that there was rigging no no it
doesn't because even if there was some
kind of clandestine deal made to keep
her in the race so that she could take
votes from Bernie so what that's the way
the game is played in politics voters
still had to choose to go to the polls
and throw their vote away by giving it
or her staying in the race doesn't mean
that people are compelled to vote for
her and throw their vote away that way
it just means that they can if they want
to they have to choose that voters
aren't sheep
now they might act like it but they
aren't literally sheep they aren't
automatons they're adults technically
making choices and as long as those
choices are reflected accurately in the
tally at the end of the night then it's
not rigged period did the establishment
force people to vote for Warren no they
could have been smart they could have
said gee I'm a far leftist I have these
ideological priorities Warren isn't
gonna win Bernie Sanders reflects those
priorities he's got the best chance I'll
vote for him they could have done that
that's the smart thing to do but they
decided to do the stupid thing they
didn't have to do the stupid thing they
did because they're stupid people the
fact that stupid people can be
manipulated doesn't mean that elections
are rigged our whole election season is
all about manipulating stupid people
I've got news for you that's all it is
every single ad you see for a politician
on TV that is always about manipulating
stupid people because you have to be a
stupid person to be influenced by a
political head if you're even moderately
intelligent though you've never seen a
political ad that influence your vote
one way or another because it's an ad
you know you're only getting one side of
the story obviously it's it's incredibly
biased of course that's what it's
supposed to be it's an ad for a
candidate you're not gonna learn
anything about this person from an
advertisement yet people spend millions
hundreds of michael bloomberg spent
hundreds of millions on add-on ads
because they do influence people stupid
people and there are a lot of stupid
people in America that doesn't mean the
elections are rigged though it just
means we have a problem of stupidity
what about the possibility that the
establishment convinced Budaj included
Club a char or club a char how about
that to drop out before Super Tuesday
that's the other theory conspiracy
theory that the establishment went to
them and said you got to drop out so we
can get the votes to buy it in and keep
Bernie ax that very likely probably did
happen is that rigging then no not even
close it's not even close to a rigged
election because it's not
the choice from people when they go to
the polls yeah they can't choose Buddha
ginger clove which are anymore but that
doesn't mean they have to vote for Biden
they can still make whatever choice they
want politicians are very good at
predicting what stupid people will do
and arranging things so that the
predictable actions of stupid people
will benefit them as politicians but
once again that is not rigging an
election that's just playing the game
that's just politics see this is what I
don't like about the election rigging
claim it infantilizes the voter it makes
the voter into a victim of his own
decisions and the whole thing is just
another symptom of of entitlement it's
another symptom of the the problem we
have in this country
generally speaking culturally the voters
go out they make choices and then they
cry about the choices they made they
think they have some kind of god-given
right for everything to work out exactly
as they want it to even if their own
actions undermine their own goals people
go out and do things to undermine their
own goals they do things against their
own interests and then things don't work
out in their interests and they cry and
say everything is rigged everyone's
against me
no you're just an idiot who just who
made a stupid decision this is why the
country is how it is this is why we have
the leaders that we do because of this
kind of petulant adolescent attitude our
political class all this whining people
do about the elites in the political
class where do you think they come from
how do you think they got there every
single politician they are there because
we put them there they didn't they
didn't they weren't dug out of the
ground like orcs and lord of the rings'
we put them there every single one and
then we cry about it we said what are
these people doing there we marched to
the polls crying as we vote for the
people we don't want and then they do
things that we don't like we said how
did this happen
don't understand what's going on and
then we you know and then we just sit
down and turn on the TV and binge
Netflix for seven hours and forget about
it it's just you know let's take some
responsibility for all this stuff
the fact is election day if if most
people vote for a certain person that
person's gonna win whether it's
President or senator or whatever office
it is if most people vote for them
they're gonna win if they don't win it's
because most people didn't vote for them
I know that there's there are things
that that happen there's a there's
there's a voter fraud is is an issue it
does happen but it's not happening on
such a scale that we end up with you
know that that presidents are elected on
the basis of it I mean and I you know
Trumpy this is something you hear from a
lot of Trump supporters vote-rigging
well Trump won in in 2016 he won without
even winning the popular vote right well
that's the way the system is set up
electoral college
so is that was that rigged you would say
well no that wasn't rigged that's how it
was supposed to be if he loses though
then it's rigged come on no if Trump
wins in 2020 which I think at this point
you will if he wins it's because most
people voted for him or at least the
right people in the right States voted
for him so he could win the electoral
college if he doesn't win it's because
he lost because people didn't want yeah
you know it and that's maybe they should
want maybe they should but that's people
are just making choices we're not
victims of our choices and I wish we
could all just understand that we make
choices and they are our choices we're
not victims of them we are not victims
of any of these buffoons in Washington
and I can't stand almost all of them yet
did put them there and we have to face
that all right let's move on to
headlines but before we do I want to
tell you about helix sleep helix sleep
has a quiz that takes you just 2 minutes
to complete I took the quiz
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattresses
for you if you like a mattress that's
really soft or firm if you sleep on your
side your back your stomach if you get
really hot when you sleep whatever it
whatever it is with with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique tastes unique
preferences and body types you don't
need to take their word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress of 2019 and 2020 by GQ and
Wired magazine they've got a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but I guarantee you will we had they
were nice enough to ship a mattress over
to us and I test it out so it is
honestly an extremely comfortable
mattress and I'm a little bit bitter
about it because when the mattress came
my wife said oh you know our daughter
our daughter needs a new mattress which
she did and somehow I said let's let's
give the mattress to her and I said but
it's really comfortable I I want it and
see this is a problem with my wife and
problem with a lot of wives is that
they're always thinking about the kids
are thinking about others you know it's
it's really a problem because what about
me that's that's that's what I'm saying
so he gave the mattress to my daughter
and she she sleeps very very soundly in
it and I'm bitter about it every single
night now right now helix is offering up
to $200 off and free pillows with all
mattresses orders or for all of our
listeners at helix sleep comm slash
Walsh
that's helix sleep comm slash walls for
up to $200 off your mattress order again
that's $200 off your mattress order
that's helix sleep dot-com slash Walsh
ok let's go to headlines we've already
covered number one the results of Super
Tuesday but I think the biggest moment
happened during our during Joe Biden's
speech which you know having an elderly
man who's already losing his mind to
give a speech at 11 o'clock at night
when it's four hours past his bedtime
four hours past the time when everybody
else's ages asleep you know it's not
gonna work out very well especially when
it's Joe Biden we're talking about and
and yeah it kind of went off the rails
almost immediately
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh geez Joe Joe Joe Joe well as I said
last night
it seems that by calling his sister his
wife Joe Biden is you might say he's
making a bold play for Ilhan Omar
supporters so maybe there was some
political calculation there and he did
win Minnesota which is Omar's state so
who knows maybe there's a connection
there
number two David Frum editor of the
Atlantic got himself into trouble last
night while offering his analysis about
the results and about Bernie supporters
verse Joe Biden supporters here's what
he said
joepie he appeals to people who pay
their cable the cable bills on the day
it arrives Bernie Sanders appeals to
people who may forget to pay the cable
bill entirely and there was an the first
group there both morally were legally
morally worthy but the first group are
more reliable let me just say that is
outrageous it is outrageous and
offensive it's not true in these kinds
of stereotypes I'm not gonna stand for
them it's not true that Bernie Sanders
Sanders supporters don't pay their
capability cable bills on time not true
at all in fact Bernie Sanders supporters
make sure that their parents pay for all
their bills on time and their I know
this about them okay I know these people
they're they're very strict about it
with their parents if their parents
forget to pay the cable bill or the you
know electric bill or anything they're
gonna be on the horn with mom saying mom
what's going on they're gonna hold her
feet to the fire so they are there on
top of it these are very responsible
people number three you may think it I
wouldn't blame you for thinking that
ESPN cannot possibly embarrass himself
anymore
it already has over the over recent
years but you would be wrong I'm afraid
yesterday ESPN managed somehow to sink
to a new level of cringe or maybe rise
to a new level of cringe depending on
how you feel about cringe I'm a big fan
of cringe which is why my favorite
episode of the office is the dinner
party but in any case on ESPN the show
first take on the SPN with professional
Yeller Steven Highsmith they did a whole
lengthy segment with with Spike Lee film
director Spike Lee now Spike Lee as
you'll see in a moment is a ridiculous
person also a bad filmmaker the latter
isn't really relevant here the fact that
he's a ridiculous person is relevant and
you'll see why now it seems that Spike
Lee who's a big New York's New York
Knicks fan for some reason went to
Madison Square Garden a few nights ago
to watch the Knicks and he tried to go
in the employee entrance even though
he's not an employee and he was pulled
by security that well you can't go in
that entrance because they're not an
employee seems pretty reasonable you
don't work here so you can't go in that
entrance they told him that they had a
special VIP entrance for him because
he's a famous guy and so he gets special
stuff and they say can you go to the VIP
entrance and and and and this
altercation this minor inconvenience
caused Spike Lee to have a temper
tantrum a meltdown like the spoiled rich
baby that he is ESPN then brought him on
the air to complain about not being able
to use the employee entrance at Madison
Square Garden and they expect us it's
not just that they brought him on the
air to talk about it so take a laugh at
him I'd understand that no it's that
they they expect us to be outraged
Stephen a Smith was outraged about this
he was ranting about it on Twitter too
he wants us to be really upset that
Spike Lee was not able to use the
employee insurance at Madison Square
Garden here is Spike Lee talking about
this great tragedy that he suffered I've
been used in the st. entrance for
20-plus years it employs inches on 33rd
Street yesterday last night I go in my
ticket gets scanned I'm in I well you
know the elevator yes
elevator an elevator also people having
a tickets can also and elevators not
moving and the security guy come to me
said we need to get off the elevator I
said for what so we could speak about an
ass I'm not getting out of elevator so
there's another five minutes then they
probably said Ellery up because they
know I'm not did not elevator get on the
elevator as you know if you don't know
the gardener floors on the fifth floor I
think up to five and scurries waiting
for you like it just ran on a Mason
stealing something and they said you dis
guy security guy they're all just comes
to the top he says mr. League you have
to leave Madison Square Garden they
wanted me to leave the garden walk
outside that out the 33rd Street
employer who I came from walk outside
and come back on 31st Street oh you had
you had to come in on 31st Street really
that oh oh that's that's oh no 31st
Street you need to walk outside and go
around to a different entrance i oh my
gosh Spike Lee
nobody has ever suffered like you have
this is this is an injustice of historic
proportion they will build monuments to
this moment people will come from from
miles around from from countries across
the world
it's a mourn and weep and remember this
tragedy let the world never forget
lest we ever forget what happened at
Madison Square Garden that night the
night that a celebrity was was was was
was forced to use the celebrity entrance
rather than the employee entrance he had
to get off an elevator they wanted him
to get off an elevator unbelievable
I'm trying sorry spike I'm trying trying
to muster the outrage and I'm pretty
good at mustering outrage that's what I
do for a living but I it's I'm having a
tough time with this
and of course we all know if this was a
rich white man crying that he couldn't
use the employee entrance to access
Madison Square Garden to get to his
private suite do you think ESPN would
have given him the time of day
you think anybody would be interested in
hearing that no of course not
number four reading from a report in The
Daily wire says a new study on climate
anxiety found that same child activist
Greta Thune Berg is not the only young
person who has suffered from severe
stress as a result of taking dire
predictions about the planet the planet
by climate alarmists to heart the BBC
News round reports says climate anxiety
survey for BBC News rounds shows
children losing sleep over climate
change and the environment this is a
survey of 8 to 16 year old young people
news round explains are frustrated and
anxious about what's happening a
majority 58 percent of 2000 children
interviewed said they were worried about
the impact of global warming about one
out of every five said that they had
nightmares about it but the same
percentage 17 percent said they're
sleeping and eating habits have been
affected by their fears about climate
change this is now here here is a reason
for authentic outrage that this is
what's what's happening to our kids and
it's understandable that kids would be
losing sleep about it because kids don't
know anything about science obviously
and if you tell them that the world is
coming to an end in just a few years and
we're all gonna drown when the ice caps
melt and all this kind of stuff they're
gonna believe you and of course they're
gonna be scared about that which is why
climate alarmism is is child abuse when
you keep it on a kid like this and you
you you give the child these existential
fears that they now have to live with
that are completely gratuitous because
no credible scientist actually thinks
that the world is coming to an end
anytime soon because of climate change
this is something from politicians and
they have no problem putting this on
kids and manipulating kids as a means of
manipulating adults as well and because
they know that those kids are going
and voters one day and so if you can
make them paranoid climate alarmists
from a young age then they're gonna be
easy to manipulate speaking of
manipulating voters and you're gonna be
able to get what you want out of them if
you're if you're a you know a leftist
politician so it's just it's it's pretty
infuriating number five they're making
another reboot of Cinderella because we
have to have a reboot of Cinderella once
every nine months approximately this is
just a this is a story apparently that
it it just an infinite fountain of
reboots it never gets old
I guess now I think it does get old at a
certain point okay we get it we've heard
the Cinderella story it's a good story
not get me wrong I don't know if we need
6,000 versions of it I think maybe just
5,000 versions we could probably would
probably suffice but in this version
apparently the actor Billy Porter who is
the attention-starved dude who shows up
to award shows in ugly dresses that's
his thing you've probably seen him
online well anyway he says he's gonna
play a genderless version of the fairy
godmother he's gonna he's gonna play the
fairy godmother in this woke remake and
it's gonna be a genderless even though
he himself is not generous and of course
the word fairy godmother would seem to
indicate gender so is it gonna be the
fairy god thing but I guess that's what
Joe Biden would call it the thing now
okay here's an idea
now I'm brainstorming a of Cinderella
where the fairy godmother is replaced
with the thing from the movie the thing
now that's that is a remake I'd like to
see and if that's what we're talking
about here then I'm all on board for it
but you have to love this value because
what we have near now are men stealing
roles from women in the name of progress
this is progress now for men to take
roles from women so that's great all
right moving on
let's go to your daily cancellation I
mentioned
footage about of Bloomberg I do feel a
little bad adding insult to injury but
III just feel like we can't allow this
one to go unremarked upon so I'm gonna
play this footage for you in a second if
you haven't seen it what it shows is
Bloomberg at a campaign stop a few days
ago in Virginia grabbing a slice of
pizza from a box ripping off a piece
putting it in his mouth
licking his fingers putting his hand
back in the box extracting a clump of
cheese from another piece licking each
finger methodically like a serial killer
and then placing his hand directly on a
large carton of coffee the mere sight of
this spectacle is enough to give PTSD to
germophobes like myself even a mild
germaphobe I think would be would be
traumatized by this we cannot lose sight
of the irony here Bloomberg engaged in
this act of biological terrorism less
than 24 hours after he gave a speech
where he was pretending to be the
president and talking about the corona
virus and that speech was was already
pathetic but now that he's dropped out
of the race and by the way endorsed Joe
Biden it just makes it all the sadder
anyway but but he gives that speech
about the corona virus and then he turns
around and does this apparently his way
of battling the the corona virus is to
sprinkle whatever ancient and mysterious
communicable diseases are bouncing
around his 78 year old body sprinkled
him all over the pizza like Parmesan
cheese so should this video alone
disqualify him from the presidency well
well he's already disqualified himself
but of course it should it should
disqualify anybody should it disqualify
him from citizenship should he hid
should he have his citizenship revoked
I think obviously yes should there be
even harsher penalties than that I think
again clearly you know it goes without
saying under my regime finger liquors
people would shoot with their mouths
open double dippers
all of those you know we're gonna start
with with imprisonment at a minimum and
then and then we'll go from there and
you know of course and because I'm a
merciful and just person I would take it
on a case-by-case basis
I would assess moral culpability and all
those kinds of things in the worst cases
you know we would be looking at
execution of course let's consider some
of the particulars here though with this
with this video first of all before we
even get to the part where he's
slobbering all over everybody in the
room who who serves coffee with pizza
who puts coffee and pizza in the same
spread coffee is a diuretic pizza is
congealed grease in the form of food you
don't combine those two things in the
same bowels that's like throwing a whole
pack of mentos into a two liter of coke
it's just it's it's not a good thing to
combine also taste wise it doesn't work
everyone knows you having a pizza party
beer and soda
now beers a diuretic too but you know
it's beer so it's okay second thing
people who lick their fingers in general
are and no offense intended
degenerate freaks god-made napkins for a
reason nobody wants to see or hear you
slurping the food particles off of your
off of your own limbs like some sort of
animal and then when you consider all
the bacteria that you have under your
fingernails you ever look that up it's a
cornucopia of bacteria under your
fingernails and and and your slurping
that off your finger so it's you might
as well eat oatmeal out of a urinal it's
it's the same thing as far as the germs
go but at least the average finger
sucker has the decency to wash their
hands after they do it before touching
anything at least I tell myself they
wash their hands because I have to tell
myself that to keep myself from stabbing
them but Blumberg not only didn't wash
his hands but seemingly made a point of
touching all the food products in the
vicinity like like a feral cat marking
his territory and here's the thing that
is just about the only thing that
actually would salvage Bloomberg's
decency or whatever's left of it
he were to say to offer the excuse that
he licked his fingers and then touch the
pizza in order to stop other people from
eating the pizza so that he could eat it
and have it all to himself then I would
say well that is selfish and rude but
it's also shrewd from a strategic
perspective I would respect it I would
respect the game even if I'm repulsed by
it
but I think this was not a tactile move
a tactical move from on Bloomberg's part
I think he had no intention of eating
all the Pete's I think all he wanted was
that one little clump of cheese he just
didn't care if he shared his slobber
with the entire room and that makes him
a psychopath a terrorist unfit for some
civilized society and we can add it to
all of the many reasons to be glad that
he has now dropped out of the race and
is cancelled cancelled twice over all
right let's go to emails Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Rubin says hi I just
subscribe to The Daily wire this past
November and feel a little late to the
party I thoroughly enjoy most of the
shows but particularly appreciate that
Matt doesn't cover the exact same topics
as the other guys Ben gives a fair
account of political events and provides
his conservative take Michael and Andrew
or deep in the tank for the right but
they're entertaining and open about it
so I appreciate that then there's mr.
Walsh who tackles the moral issues and
threats confronting our culture it's a
paradoxical breath of fresh air during
the day to turn from the constant
undermining of our country by the left
to the attack of unarmed morality by the
left but who is Matt Walsh
why is he never on backstage why isn't
he in the studio with the rest of the
guys I'm completely lost and why he
seems to be just a guy with a mic that
they allow to use their platform of The
Daily wire is there something that I
should know or am missing any
clarification would be great thanks well
Ruben you asked who is Matt Walsh I am
just a man with hopes and dreams and a
plan to enslave mankind and carry out
mass executions of everybody who annoys
me that's and that's really what this
show is about as you've already been
able to tell and that's what I'm about
as a person and I think that
the core of Who I am so I hope that
answers your question
I also hope it explains why they keep me
in a cave 3,000 miles away let's go to
John says hey Matt first of all big fans
show listen your show almost every day
my buddy and I love listening to your
takes on logical thinking when it comes
to cultural political issues my question
pertains to the relationship between
Pollock politics in the church growing
up in a conservative Christian household
raised by by a conservative Christian
parents I've always been surrounded by
this idea of living a moral life and
finding purpose through the Christian
faith as admirable as all this sounds do
you think that Christians of the church
have any responsibility or moral
culpability when it comes to tackling
polarizing and divisive cultural and
political issues I haven't read your
book Church of cowards yet but the very
premise of the book seems to point to a
larger problem and symptoms within
Christian and conservative circles I
very much agree with you that
conservatives and Christians need to be
more combative and maybe more aggressive
when discussing these things in old but
timeless quote from Ralph Nader back in
the day has stuck with me when thinking
about this subject turn on to politics
or politics will turn on you I'd love to
hear your thoughts John well John thanks
for the email and also thanks for the
chance that you gave me to hawk my book
Church of cowards which is in stores now
wherever books are sold go to Amazon and
buy it obviously I agree with what you
said here and this is a big part of why
I wrote the book Church of cowards and
what I address in the book yes the
church has a profound responsibility to
engage with show leadership on lend
clarity to the cultural and social
issues of the day I've often said you
know as I say also in the book that
entering into a church should be
entering into something sacred something
set apart something elevated but that
doesn't mean that it should be something
irrelevant to your daily life precisely
the opposite the problem is that so many
churches have tried hard to make the
church experience reflect on the surface
anyway superficially the culture and so
that you walk into a church and and
everything from the architecture to the
music to the message everything you can
hardly even tell you're in a church
that's what so many churches have done
but then when it comes to that message
it's completely irrelevant it's it's it
doesn't speak to the experiences of the
people in the congregation it doesn't
speak to the moral and spiritual battles
they face face it doesn't speak to the
anxieties and fears and longings they
have living in modern culture raising
children in modern culture so this is
entirely backwards the reality is
whether we like it or not and I
certainly don't like it we live in a
world where children are exploited and
murdered where the family is under
attack marriage is under attack basic
moral truths are undermined faith is
maligned and on and on and on if the
church will not address that will not
speak boldly to that and about that
giving people direction and how to
navigate it and encouragement in in
their battles out there on the
battlefield of modern culture then
people are gonna start saying what do I
even need you for what do I need any of
this for what's the point of this and I
think that's what's increasingly
happened happening where the church and
church leaders in their cowardice and
their not wanting to overturn the apple
cart or upset people they have made
faith seem irrelevant even though it is
and they made it seem irrelevant to
people and people say this is useless
well you know it's what's the point of
this
and that's just a tragedy and that's the
tragedy I talk about the book finally
this is from Heather as we find out why
I'm wrong here's your why I'm wrong
email of the day from Heather says Matt
you're wrong about sexual harassment
it's true that women do flirt with men
you're right about that but the
difference is that women don't have the
same physical power and ability to force
themselves on others sexual harassment
is a more serious problem for men even
if it isn't more common from men that's
what you're missing well thanks Heather
first of all keep in mind even if I
agreed with you and I do agree with some
of what you're saying my point yesterday
is that by the standards of the culture
according to what is said about men and
women that argument doesn't fly so the
same people who are on this witch-hunt
against sexual harassment are largely
the people who would say that men and
women are basically the same and and
aren't really different and women aren't
necessarily stronger than than women
anyway so you they can't use the
argument that you just presented which
is why they by their own standard must
take male and female harassment equally
as serious I mean don't tell me in one
breath that women can be on the front
lines of combats because they're capable
of being just as menacing and lethal as
men and then in the next breath tell me
that it doesn't matter when they harass
men because they're just petite little
flowers that could never harm a fly
those two things don't work now putting
that aside back in reality where we
realize that men and women are different
I still say there's a double standard
yes men are more capable of forcing
themselves on women but that shouldn't
lead to and does not justify a dichotomy
where women are almost never called out
for sexual harassment and men are called
out for it even when they do something
you know as innocuous as complimenting a
woman on her appearance this kind of
situation can't be rationalized on the
sole basis that men are stronger yeah
that might make their harassment in some
circumstances more serious in some
circumstances but if harassment is wrong
then
it's wrong and if complimenting somebody
on their appearance is harassment
then it's harassment and it's harassment
when women do it too now I don't think
it is harassment but if that's your your
your take on it if that's what you think
then you have to say it about women same
for flirting same for sexual comments
that are made women do all of that
now when it comes to something like
initiating a flirtatious exchange I
don't buy for a second that men are more
likely to do that or do it more often or
do it in more inappropriate
circumstances I don't think that's true
at all
III think at a minimum its equal if
anything maybe women are more guilty but
but but you certainly can't say I just I
don't think there's any basis to say
that men are more guilty of that than
women are now some of this stuff
depending on the situation some of this
stuff can be sexual harassment but if it
it would also be that when women do it
yet they're almost never called out for
it they're almost never condemned for it
nobody takes it seriously and even when
you go into things that are much more
serious than mere sexual harassment we
talk about sexual activity talk about an
adult having sex with a with a with a
minor for example like all of these
female teachers who are you know having
sex with with 12 and 13 or 14 year old
boys which is which is actually an
epidemic across the country as I have
tried to call attention to for for many
years now the sexual abuse problem in
the public school system not just among
female teachers but male teachers too
but the sexual abuse problem in this
public school system is an epidemic it
is it is it's tens of thousands of kids
are being sexually abused in the public
school system nobody talks about it we
especially don't well when it comes to
the women doing it we may talk about it
but we talked about it in this kind of
joking way that we would never ever ever
do
if the genders are reversed again double
standard and that's what I'm that's what
I'm calling attention to I'm saying that
there should be one standard we can get
into assessing you know seriousness of
this and that thing but but if sexual
harassment is wrong which it is it's
wrong when anyone does it
if complimenting someone is is
harassment which it isn't but if it is
if you're arguing that it is then it
then it's it that's the case for men and
women and that's my point all right
we'll leave it there thank somebody for
watching thanks for listening
have a great day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 Joe Biden turns around a flailing
presidential campaign with a massive
showing on Super Tuesday whereas last
week Joe was dead both literally and
figuratively
now he's only dead literally we will
examine what the establishment comeback
means for the Democratic primary and for
the general election then the media are
shocked that a Hispanic could vote for
president Trump disgraced throuple
congresswoman Katie hill teaches us all
a lesson on selfishness and Taylor Swift
hates men all that and more check it out
on the Michael Noel's show
[Music]